fünfzehnter februar 2020
er freut sich wie so viele auf die
abendliche kappensitzung
wir nennen ihnen peter m seine
geschichte haben wir anhand realer
ereignisse nachgestellt schon den ganzen
tag über fühlte sich nicht wirklich fit
doch die langersehnte feier in der
bürgerhalle gangelt langenbruch will er
sich nicht entgehen lassen
gemeinsam mit einem bekannten will es
sich heute auf den weg ins carnevals
getümmel machen und damit nimmt der
abend seinen verhängnisvollen lauf
[Gelächter]
kurz nach 19 uhr der saal füllt sich wie
in jedem jahr sind die 300 sitzplätze in
der bürgerhalle blitzschnell ausverkauft
und im laufe des abends kommen immer
noch mehr jako hinzu
[Musik]
peter m sitzt in geselliger runde an
einem der tische hier kennen sich alle
abstand halten ist ein karneval ein
absurder gedanke es wird getrunken
palavert gesungen bejubelt und wie
üblich in den tollen tagen ganz viel
geblitzt
auch sie sind im vergangenen jahr bei
der verhängnisvollen feier dabei stefan
keulen der sitzungspräsident des abends
und roman mertens die beiden sind
mitglieder des karnevalsvereins lang
bröker dicke klar der seit vielen jahren
die kappensitzung ausrichtet die männer
gehen mit uns an den ort wo sich viele
menschen infiziert haben ohne es zu
ahnen von corona ausbruch in china
hatten sie gehört dass das virus aber
ausgerechnet ihr dorf zu einem hotspot
machen würde
das war für sie unvorstellbar also man
hat natürlich wahrgenommen wenn man
abends die nachrichten geschaut hat aber
wo haben ist ja ganz weit weg und ich
glaube es ist ja gerne bei solchen
geschehen und bei solchen katastrophen
so dass man die gerne auch weit weg hat
und kann sie gar nicht so sehr an sich
ran lassen kommen würde
roman mertens zapft an diesem abend bier
und steht als sänger auf der bühne
auch der 47 jährige gehört zu den
feiernden die sich damals mit corona
infizieren
bei mir war der krankheitsverlauf ist
eher mild ich hatte nur ganz leichte
erkältungssymptome aber es war sogar so
dass mehrere fälle tatsächlich in meinem
engsten umfeld da waren die nicht mild
verlaufen sind sondern die sehr schlimm
verlaufen sind und wir auch einen
todesfall einer familie hatten
am abend der veranstaltung sind alle
noch ahnungslos nach 21 uhr ist die
stimmung in der bürgerhalle auf dem
höhepunkt peter any generiert seine
vermeintliche erkältung und bekämpft das
kratzen im hals mit alkohol
inzwischen steht fest peter es damals an
cupid 19 erkrankt und er ist nicht der
einzige
eine spätere studie der uniklinik bonn
zeigt unter den feiernden sind
wahrscheinlich mehrere super spread und
das virus verteilt sich an dem abend im
gesamten saal des corona virus breitet
sich am besten dort aus wo viele
menschen eng beisammen sind meistens
wird es über tröpfchen übertragen aber
wie wir heute wissen unter bestimmten
bedingungen auch über sogenannte
aerosole aerosole sind winzig kleine
tropfen kerne die lange zeit in der luft
stehen können und meter weit getragen
werden die bürgerhalle bot hierfür
ideale bedingungen unter den feiernden
waren mehrere infizierte die beim
sprechen singen und lachen er o sohle
abgaben die mit ihren beladen waren
diese wurden durch die belüftungsanlage
zwar angesagt aber der einfache filter
konnte sie nicht zurückhalten und so
gelangte an anderer stelle im saal viren
haltige luft wieder zurück direkt über
dem tresen wurde die luft auch
ausgepustet und hier steckten sich die
meisten gäste an
knapp die hälfte der rund 450 gäste
infiziert sich an dem abend zwei tage
nach der kappensitzung geht es peter l
immer schlechter jede bewegung fällt ihm
schwer
seine lunge schmerzt
zudem hat er hohes fieber entwickelt
peter ins hoffnung ist dass die
vermeintliche grippe bald verschwindet
noch immer ahnt er nicht dass er mit dem
neuen corona virus auf 2 infiziert ist
hoch ansteckend wie die anderen
infizierten trägt er in den tagen nach
der kappensitzung so dazu bei dass sich
das virus schnell verbreitet
im gesamten landkreis heinsberg kommt es
zu einem exponentiellen anstieg von
teils schweren ko witt 19 erkrankungen
in heinsberg haben wir gesehen wie
leicht sich das saas kopf 2 virus
verbreitet dafür reicht manchmal ein
normales tischgespräch einige menschen
sind so genannte super sprit und wir
vermuten dass sie besonders viele viren
über ihre sohle ausscheiden
je mehr viren ausgeschieden werden also
je höher die viruslast desto
wahrscheinlicher ist es dass sich jemand
infiziert aber nicht nur das wir haben
hinweise darauf dass die anfängliche
virus last also wie viele viren man
aufnimmt den schweregrad des
krankheitsverlaufs beeinflusst wird das
virus eingeatmet infiziertes erste
zählen im rachen
je mehr viren aufgenommen werden um so
mehr infektionsherde entstehen meistens
kann das immunsystem die infektion im
rachen und in der nase in schach halten
und das virus bereits besiegen
manchmal gelangt es arbeiten die unteren
atemwege und kann dort eine schwere
lungenentzündung hervorrufen
dann kann es zu harten beschwerden und
atemnot kommen
von mir aus kann es auch andere organe
befallen und langfristig schäden an
nieren lunge und nervensystem
verursachen erkenntnisse die es bei der
kappensitzung noch nicht gibt im januar
2020 wird in der chinesischen metropole
wo hahn nach ausbruch des corona virus
ein shutdown verhängt innerhalb weniger
tage werden spezialkliniken gebaut
doch für die deutschen scheint das
damals noch ein weit entfernt das
problem zu sein
bereits am 27 januar gibt es den ersten
corner fall in deutschland ein
mitarbeiter einer bayrischen firma ist
erkrankt
am 11 februar dann ruft die whu den
internationalen gesundheitsnotfall aus
und gibt der neuen erkrankung einnahmen
disco hit mein team
die bundesregierung reagiert auch jetzt
noch gelassen
die gefahr für die gesundheit der
bevölkerung in deutschland durch die
neue atemwegserkrankung schätzt das
robert koch institut aktuell weiterhin
als gering ein
wir sind wachsam wir sind aufmerksam
wir sind gut vorbereitet er 22 februar
ein 78 jähriger italiener stirbt der
erste tote europäer bergamo wird zum
corona hotspot
die bilder von militärfahrzeugen die
särge durch die stadt fahren gehen um
die welt
drei tage später am 25
februar geht in der kreisverwaltung
heinsberg die meldung ein dass gäste der
kappensitzung mit cupid 19 symptomen im
krankenhaus liegen über das neue virus
ist immer noch so gut wie nichts bekannt
landrat stephan pusch wird zum
krisenmanager lag auf der couch war mich
so ein bisschen von den karnevalstagen
erholen und kriegt den anruf von meinem
stellvertreter hör mal wir haben gerade
die mitteilung bekommen
die leitstelle wir haben zwei personen
die schwer an krone erkrankt sind die
also auch intensiv behandelt werden muss
beatmet werden müssen
das waren schon dramatische stunden und
einem war schon ziemlich mulmig auch
also muss man sagen kitas und schulen
werden geschlossen
stephan pusch für den gesamten landkreis
heinsberg in den ersten shut down
deutschlands
bitte sie als landrat des kreises
heinsberg 19 ruhe zu bewahren bleiben
sie bitte zu hause das öffentliche leben
erstaunt die stimmung gespenstisch
praxen müssen schließen weil sich ärzte
infizieren
es fehlt an desinfektionsmitteln
schutzkleidung und beatmungsgeräte
werden knappen das virus trifft den
kreis unvorbereitet stephan pusch
verhindert schlimmeres
wenn ich darauf gewartet hätte in den
ersten tagen was jetzt für anweisungen
vom land gekommen wäre was zu tun
gewesen wäre und wir nicht so schnell
entschieden hätten dann wäre uns für die
medizinische situation in ersten tag
total aus dem ruder gelaufen
gangelt ort der kappensitzung wird zum
forschungsfeld ein wissenschaftsteam der
uniklinik bonn nimmt proben von
erkrankten und vollzieht die ausbreitung
wege nach die sogenannte heinsberg
studie liefert erste detaillierte
erkenntnisse über ein deutsches super
spreading event die wichtigsten
ergebnisse mit 19 erkrankungen haben
häufig den verlust des geschmacks ins
zur folge jede fünfte infektion verläuft
hier ohne symptome
und die dunkelziffer in gangelt ist
fünffach höher als die gemeldeten
infektionen
drei wochen nach der karnevalssitzung
müssen mehrere gäste noch immer
intensivmedizinisch betreut werden
bei peter m hat sich eine
lungenentzündung entwickelt die
behandelnden ärzte stehen vor einer
großen herausforderung welche therapie
ist bei der neuen erkrankung die
richtige zeitgleich schnellt die zahl
der infizierten in ganz deutschland nach
oben
die fälle mit schwerem verlauf holten
sich am neunten märz ist endgültig klar
wie gefährlich corona ist
in deutschland gibt es die ersten beiden
bestätigten todesfälle wegen des corona
virus laut gesundheitsministerium nrw
handelt sich um eine person im kreis
heinsberg und eine in essen hier in der
uniklinik essen stirbt eine seniorin im
märz 2020 zu dieser zeit herrscht dort
ausnahmezustand wir haben die normalen
klinik prozesse wie operation oder
ähnliches angepasst verschoben wirklich
alles auf kur wird 19 ausgerichtet das
war aber sicherlich eine sehr
ungewöhnliche situation weil wir alle
noch niemals in der pandemie gearbeitet
haben und man wusste eben nicht was
passiert seitdem hat oberärztin dr
carola holzner das typische cupid 19
krankheitsbild oft gesehen eine schwer
angegriffen
wir sehen gesundes gewebe dass es hier
schwarz dargestellt das weiße gewebe ist
krankes gewebe die lunge ist sehr
gefallen es gibt mehr kränker als
besonders bewegung und das führt eben
dazu dass der patient bekommt und auch
unterstützung braucht die vielen kurven
19 erkrankten bereiten der
intensivmediziner rinn sorgen
und es sind eben nicht nur die chronisch
kranken älteren sondern es sind auch
jüngere patienten und wenn man dann
jemanden der vielleicht nur ein zwei
jahre älter ist als man selber mit
seinem ausgeprägten ct bild was ich in
der notaufnahme hat dann denkt man schon
darüber nach
peter m bleibt wochenlang im krankenhaus
hat atembeschwerden noch immer strengt
ihn jede bewegung an
ob er bleibende gesundheitliche schäden
davon trägt steht noch nicht fest peter
n steht jetzt eine mehrwöchige re habe
vor
[Musik]
seine reha wird ihnen noch viele monate
begleiten
der weg zurück in den alltag fällt ihm
schwer vor einem jahr fing sich jörg
pütz das saas q2 virus 14 monate lang
lag er im krankenhaus
dass er jetzt wieder eine treppe steigen
kann grenzt an ein wunder
die überlebenschancen lagen bei unter
zehn prozent und es war mehr als
dramatisch
meine frau mussten sie sich auch nicht
mit selbst hat dann den pastor angerufen
der hat mir dann die letzte ölung oder
eben die krankensalbung gegeben hat sich
von mir verabschiedet und hat auch nicht
damit gerechnet sagt er mich noch mal
lebend wiedersehen würde seine
dramatischen fotos aus dem krankenhaus
stellt jörg pütz bewusst zur verfügung
er will warnen und aufrütteln und kann
nicht nachvollziehen dass es immer noch
menschen gibt die das virus verharmlosen
[Musik]
rückblick ihr kitz ist präsident eines
karnevalsvereins der 58 jährige besucht
im februar 2020 in seiner heimatstadt
bad honnef etliche veranstaltungen ist
auch beim rosenmontagszug in köln dabei
dann plötzlich kann der asthmatiker kaum
noch atmen und wird in die notaufnahme
eingeliefert
ich konnte vier finger an der linken
hand bewegen ich konnte nicht sprechen
und das schlimmste war ich konnte keinen
besuch bekommen weil ich ja eben noch
isoliert war nicht füreinander da zu
sein
für die familie eine zeit schlimmer
emotionale erfahrungen dann eben diese
hilflosigkeit dass man einfach nicht
rein gab und der chefarzt uns gesagt hat
also rein können sie nur wenn es vorbei
geht und das telefon hat sich in der
hand wochen lang
ja wir haben gedacht bitte klingeln
nicht bloß nicht klingeln war unser
tenor wussten wenn es klingelt ist es
passiert
[Musik]
die schlimmste zeit meines lebens
wirklich so schlimm angst um einen haken
muss der einem sehr wichtig ist dann das
ist schon das kann man gar nicht
beschreiben fünf wochen legt ihr gekürzt
auf der intensivstation der uniklinik
bonn im künstlichen koma maschinen
halten ihn am leben
irgendwann haben wir jetzt so gesagt es
ist ein wunder
wir wissen nicht warum wir können es
medizinisch nicht erklären aber seit
heute gehen die werte wieder in die
richtige richtung
seine ersten worte nach dem koma hat
jörg pütz auf video festgehalten und
sehr anstrengen müssen früher einfach
die familie genießt jetzt bewusst jeden
moment zwei mal pro woche geht ja kurz
zur reha er will nicht zulassen dass ihm
ein virus den spaß am leben nennt eine
der entscheidenden fragen ist ob eine
überstandene infektionsschutz von
neuansteckung bietet das möchte auch
elisabeth zimmermann es wissen
sie war im märz 2020 an cupid 19
erkrankt ein jahr nach ihrer infektion
bekommt sie noch immer schlecht luft
jetzt ist sie probanden der aktuell
laufenden zweiten heinsberg studie
ich möchte für mich sicherheit haben
dass ich antikörper habe um mich
geschützt zu fühlen und ich möchte halt
auch die wissenschaft unterstützen denn
nur durch diese studie kommen neue
erkenntnisse und so kann man nur das
virus bekämpfen
dafür ist elisabeth zimmermanns bereit
sich mehreren tests zu unterziehen
auch heute ist sie bei ihrem hausarzt
für den rachenabstrich sowie speichel
und blutentnahme bei den ersten
untersuchungen nach ihrer infektion
wurden bei der 58-jährigen tatsächlich
antikörper nachgewiesen
ob das immer noch so ist wird sich bald
zeigen
die proben landen bei der uniklinik bonn
dort werden sie für die aktuelle studie
analysiert im rachenabstrich wird zuerst
mittels pcr tests überprüft ob aktuell
infektionen vorliegen
im blut werden dann die antikörper
untersucht dafür werden die
blutbestandteile voneinander getrennt
insgesamt nehmen über 700 probanden und
probanden an der aktuellen studie teil
dafür gibt es auch massentests in der
bürgerhalle in gangelt
die studie ist auf ein jahr angelegt und
wird voraussichtlich im sommer 2000 21
veröffentlicht folgende
zwischenergebnisse liegen abermals vor
seit beginn der studie im märz 2020 hat
sich eine person erneut mit dem virus
infiziert nach sechs monaten hatten zehn
prozent der untersuchten keine
antikörper mehr
nach neun monaten wiesen 20 prozent
keine antikörper mehr auf ob sie sich
wieder anstecken können ist aber noch
nicht bekannt
weltweit laufen derzeit an verschiedenen
forschungseinrichtungen parallel zur
heinsberg studie 2 über 1000
wissenschaftliche corona studien